bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actu en ce 31 mars nous
allons revenir au cours de la prochaine
demi heure sur les résultats du second
tour des élections municipales dans le
département et plus particulièrement sur
saint quentin en yvelines et les
communes avoisinantes
tout d'abord ce chiffre celui de
l'abstention que vous découvrez dans les
yvelines plus de 41% des électeurs ne se
sont pas déplacés aux urnes comme en
2008 la moyenne nationale est de 38% on
vote moins bien dans le département avec
des pics et d'abstention pouvant
atteindre les 55 % à trappes c'est un
nouveau record cela inquiète forcément
les représentants des partis d'autant
que se profilent dans quelques semaines
un autre scrutin qui historiquement a
déjà beaucoup de mal à mobiliser les
européennes
vous le savez si vous nous suiviez irait
en direct sur tv fil 78 lors de la
soirée spéciale préparée par la
rédaction à l'occasion du second tour
vous l'avez vécu en direct de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines n'est plus à gauche quatre des
sept communes qui la composent sont
toujours détenus par les socialistes et
les communistes mais lagos la gauche
s'étant écroulé dans les oppositions à
elancourt et à montigny le nombre d'élus
communautaires est un avantage de l'uby
et de l'ump aujourd'hui catherine mulato
pour les précisions
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise
bascule à droite une première depuis sa
création en 1973
à l'issue de ce second tour des
municipales 25 sièges échouent aux
candidats qui portent les couleurs de la
droite et 23 à ceux qui portent les
couleurs de la gauche
et ce alors que les communes conservent
leur couleur politique lui en cours
trappes et magny les hameaux reste
socialiste
la verrière communiste elle en cours
demeure ump montigny divers droite et
alexandra rosetti udi emporte voisins le
bretonneux quatre villes à gauche trois
villes à droite
une particularité qui va influer sur le
mode de gouvernance comme l'estiment à
michèle losier le maire de montigny
dimanche soir sur notre plateau on a
beaucoup d'atouts à saint quentin
on a beaucoup d'atouts à saint-quentin
moi je souhaite surtout que justement
que cette agglomération soit surtout un
outil pour les pour les communes et
qu'on réussisse ensemble et pas que ce
soit comme ça l'a été il ya quand même
pas mal de temps un outil plus
politicien en direction de certaines
formations politiques tout simplement
donc l'âme aujourd'hui je suis pour plus
de clarté plus de transparence est
effectivement que tout le monde soit
associé on a cette nouvelle gouvernance
à inventer je pense malgré tout
collectivement même si ce sera à la
charge de celui qui de sel
visiblement celui qui sera la tête de
l'agglomération de faire des
propositions mais forcément il faudra
inventer quelque chose pour réussir à
sortir de cette situation un peu et
renvoie effectivement quatre villes de
gauche peuvent être avec trois villes de
droite et avec une majorité quand même
deux sièges pour l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise à droite c'est une
révolution politique certes mais pas
tant que cela car les écarts entre la
droite et la gauche ont toujours été
serrées par exemple pendant les seize
années de gouvernance de robert
cadalbert la répartition était de 22
sièges pour la gauche et 20 pour la
droite
la différence entre un projet de gauche
de droite procès on sait ce que c'est
c'est effectivement un projet où on
accueille pour tout le monde une mixité
sociale des services publics de qualité
donc on connaît les grands fondements
entre la gauche et à droite
mais sinon
sûr que les élus quel qu'il soit la
direction de 50 ans ils ont envie que ça
continue et que ça continue à réussir à
saint quentin en yvelines
il faudra encore patienter plusieurs
jours pour connaître le nom du futur
président de la communauté
d'agglomération attendre déjà
l'installation des conseils municipaux à
30 et à voisins le bretonneux
le nouveau conseil communautaire doit se
réunir avant le 30 avril
on va regarder à présent plus en détail
les résultats sur saint quentin en
yvelines dans les deux communes qui
n'avait pas encore désigné leur mère au
premier tour ee à voisins le bretonneux
c'est une surprise alexandra rosetti
l'emportent face à alexis piette le
maire sortant il ne fera donc pas de
quatrième mandat il a été battu d'à
peine 15 voix par son ancienne première
adjointe à l'issue d'une campagne très
tendue catherine château et anthony rech
la liste voisins ma ville 2340 voix soit
41,81 bon sang de bois
la liste alexandra rosetti 2014 2355
voix soit 20,10 voie de
élu maire depuis 95 alexis piette
n'entamera pas de quatrième mandat il
est battu à 15 voix près par son
ancienne première adjointe alexandra
rosetti ancienne adjointe qui avait fait
le choix de quitter l'équipe municipale
en octobre dernier pour se lancer dans
la campagne une campagne tendue entre
les candidats qui n'aura toutefois pas
énormément mobiliser des électeurs près
de 42% ne se sont pas déplacés aux urnes
ce dimanche
alexandra rosetti ému savoure sa
victoire au micro d'anthony rech c'était
hier soir à l'annoncé des résultats
je suis effectivement très ému voilà il
y avait seulement 15 voix d'écart ça
s'est joué jusqu au dernier comptage on
a recompté on a compté le stress a dû
être jusqu'à la dernière minute
omniprésent oui c'est assez incroyable
ce va et vient de voir + 3 - 15 etc
c'est assez hallucinant donc ça veut
dire que c'est un score extrêmement
serré et ça veut dire que les vies si
noah se sont quand même mobilisé pour
élire leur nouveau maire vous avez déjà
des dossiers prioritaires
oui les dix les dossiers prioritaires je
crois c'est ce qu'on a entendu sur le
terrain beaucoup c'est tout ce qui
concerne la circulation ce qui concerne
l'aménagement de la ville ça je crois
que les gens ont beaucoup d'attentes à
ce sujet et donc c'est quelque chose
dont on va s'emparer immédiatement j'ai
quand même eu 2340 électeurs qui se sent
porté sur ma liste avec un écart très
faible pour le moment qui est de 15 voix
il est l'avenir pour vous après cette
déception pour l'instant en tout cas
mais goûter c'est de conserver la
dynamique d'une équipe extraordinaire
qui est autour de moi qui s'investira au
sein du conseil municipal en donnant
vraiment ses compétences il y aura sept
conseillers municipaux
et puis au niveau de la com d'agglo
aussi
moi même je continuerai à siéger c'est
une déception de fait on a souffert du
contexte général du pays
d'un côté et on a surtout souffert d'un
taux d'abstention beaucoup trop
important j'espère qu'alexandre
apportera quelque chose et qu'elle
travaillera avec tout le monde y compris
nous dans l'opposition j'ai toujours dit
que le changement n'était pas si évident
que ça mais je suis ouvert je ne trouve
pas que alexandra froide nécessaire donc
vous êtes prêts à travailler je suis
prêt à travailler avec elle j'étais déjà
prêt à travailler avec bettini qui a
profité mais nous avons toujours fait
une opposition constructive jamais
d'opposition systématique il ya que
l'intérêt général qui nous concerne
alexis piette battu en 2014 cela
rappelle étrangement le déroulement de
l'élection municipale de 1995
à cette époque conseiller municipal de
rené van damme le maire en place depuis
alexis piette se présente contre lui et
remporte l'élection
la vie politique est donc un éternel
recommencement attrape à présent l'autre
ville de l'agglomération dans laquelle
un second tour a été nécessaire le
candidat divers droite soutenu par l'ump
lui dénie le modem othman nasro réalise
plus de 30% des suffrages un score en
progression de 12 points par rapport à
la semaine dernière qui lui permet de
devenir la principale force d'opposition
au maire sortant socialiste guy
malandain
mais le grand gagnant de ce scrutin sur
cette ville c'est l'abstention 55,6 %
près de sept mille électeurs ne se sont
pas déplacés nous écoutons à présent les
réactions des candidats au micro de
nicolas tiré le 8 55% de mes concitoyens
ne sont pas venus voter
et voilà c'est je le regrette en temps
en tant que républicain et en tant que
démocrate après quand on passe aux
résultats et bien nous sommes à nouveau
27 conseillers municipaux de gauche à
avoir en responsabilité l'avenir de la
ville de trappes et nous allons
continuer dans cet esprit la situation
de trappe est particulière que c'est une
ville a été qui manque à ses
caractéristiques locales avec le choix
qui a été fait un choix d'adhésion ce
n'est pas un simple choix de roger je
crois qu'il ya 30% des trappistes ont
jugé que notre projet était le plus
crédible et que c'est 30 % là doivent
aujourd'hui être représenté la meilleure
des manières
je ne pense pas qu'il fallait en tirer
de conclusions sur le plan national
quand on connaît la situation politique
de trappes encore une fois moi je pense
que tu lui qui a besoin d'un vrai
changement d'une vraie opposition il ya
une forte progression de la droite
donc par rapport au premier tour qui
s'explique essentiellement
vraisemblablement par les reports de
voix des listes communautariste c'est à
dire des choix qui me semble est
dangereux pour l'avenir mais on va
prendre le temps d'analyser tout ça
tranquillement et puis il demeure que
cumuler la gauche fait plus de 70% sur
trappe donc ça c'est quand même quelque
chose de positif
on quitte l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines pour une ville
voisine maurepas à maurepas ou georges
mougeot divers gauche était en place
depuis 1989 il ne se représentait pas
cette année il avait passé la main à son
adjoint michel chapa ce dernier pendant
l'entre-deux-tours a rassemblé sur sa
liste et de nombreux adjoints issus de
la majorité sortante qui avait tenté en
solo l'aventuré au premier tour les
électeurs n'ont semble-t-il apprécié
celle outsider ump grégory gary stick
qui l'emportent
olivier maniscalco elodie mois il est
21h 30 nous sommes dans la salle du
conseil de maurepas le maire sortant
georges mougeot annonce le nom de son
successeur
monsieur l'héritier premier 207 voix
soit verte n'est lui-même
avec 49 25 % des voix grégory caret ce
qui arrive largement en tête de ce
second tour
une victoire qu'il explique par l' envie
de renouveau des bourgs patients je suis
très heureux merci au moyen de leur
confiance c'est une voiture et victoire
avec la tente
plus de 1000 voix sur mon adversaire me
sciascia pas presque 50% des voix
s'étaient voilà je pensais pas gagner
avec autant d'avancé mais ça prouve bien
que les mauriciens avaient envie de
renouvellement de renouveau d'une équipe
jeune d'une équipe sincère une équipe
sincère voilà moi qui suis démord pas
voilà c'est une consécration c'est un
rêve
donc maintenant je vais travailler
partout les mort passe bien je serai le
maire de tous les mauriciens et je vais
réveiller cette ville qui en a besoin
grégory garer stick devancé michel chapa
le candidat divers gauche soutenu par
georges mougeot qui n'obtient que 37,43
% des suffrages
suite à cette défaite michel chapa n'a
souhaité répondre à aucune interview et
a annoncé son retrait de la vie
politique
cinquième de sa liste après leurs
alliances pour le second tour michel et
enregistre le résultat sans pour autant
la prouver nous on partait sans
étiquette donc fallait tout abandonner
or on s'est retrouvé dans une
configuration de deuxième tour vous
aviez de liste étiquetée ennemis
d'intérêt local
elle arrive deuxième j'enregistre mais
je suis parti dans cette philosophique
du no d'étiquetage j'ai fait
l'expérience des partis politiques j'ai
trouvé ça triste troisième et dernier de
ce second tour ismaila vannes candidat
du ps qui récoltent 13,34 % des voix
pour lui la débâcle de la gauche c'est
la faute de l'alliance au second tour
entre michel chapa divers gauche et
pierre leguérinel exsuder y orienté à
droite
je pense que l'alliance contre nature
malaquin qui était dans l'opposition
depuis près de 25 ans avec chapeau donc
cette alliance malaquin le grenache apa
auprès de marc payen n'a pas passé in et
des gouttes les gens de la politique
c'est la politique ce n'est pas
mathématique
ce sont des valeurs et ce sont des
cohérences il y a dans la vie des fautes
politiques
je pense qu'il a fait une vote faute
politique grégory caret ski et 31 ans
fait donc basculer maurepas à droite
une première depuis 1989 avec 57,52 % de
participation à ce second tour les mort
passe bien et est en tout cas d'un 2000
points plus nombreux à voter qu'en 2009
à saint cyr l'école bernard debré ump
est réélu sans trop d'inquiétude après
être déjà arrivé largement en tête au
premier tour pourtant la majorité
sortante était divisée soulagement c'est
le mot que l'on entendait le plus
souvent chez ses partisans hier soir
clair qu'en billets étaient sur place
sans grande surprise le maire sortant
l'ump bernard de bain a été réélu hier à
saint cyr l'école sa liste d'union de la
droite recueillent 48,56 % des suffrages
exprimés et 25 sièges sur 33 au conseil
municipal
elle n'aura cependant pas réussi à
s'entendre avec gaitan desjardins
candidate sans étiquette
malgré de multiples tentatives de
tractations cette conseillère municipale
compte d'ailleurs effectué un recours
contre la liste de bernard de bain
pour diverses irrégularités dans sa
campagne le candidat portant les
couleurs de la gauche daniel garçon
arrive quant à lui en deuxième position
il gagne 10 points sur le premier tour
et cinq sièges au conseil municipal
l'élection aura en tout cas peut
mobiliser les habitants près de 44% dix
ans c'est rien se sont abstenus quand
même un grand soulagement parce que
c'était une campagne a été très longue
rifi chine dans lequel pourrait dire de
la can
j'ai essayé de ne pas répondre
je voulais que les sages rien puisse
être parfaitement informée de ce que je
pourrais pour les années à venir et
marvel fait qd au premier tour liévin
chris ray 3 lice au 2e tour
nous obtenons quand même presque la
majorité avec 25e jour 33 et surtout une
équipe formidable
d'abord il faut prendre acte de la
victoire de bernard de bain c'est la
règle en démocratie mais saint cyrien en
choisit de le reconduire ce que je peux
constater quand même c'est qu'il est
reconduit avec moins d'un saint cyrien
sur deux qui perd deux points par
rapport à son élection du premier tour
de 2008
voilà c'est ça le résultat des urnes
alors de notre côté 34 dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile au niveau
gouvernemental
on maintient nos positions et donc on va
avoir nos six élus au conseil municipal
un élu qui siégera à la communauté
d'agglomération et les saint cyriens
peuvent compter sur nous pour qu'on
continue à faire le travail qu'on fait
depuis six ans et je leur donne rendez
vous tout au long de la mandature
et puis aux prochaines échéances 2020 il
ya quand même eu
une forte abstention et monsieur demain
n'était vu qu'avec 48 56 % de voix donc
c'est un net recul par rapport à 2008 et
aujourd'hui où la droite prend des
villes et augmente son score
eh bien monsieur de bain abaissé le sien
donc ce n'est vraiment pas une victoire
et gaitan desjardins que vous venez
d'entendre qui annonce vouloir déposer
d'ici la fin de la semaine un recours en
préfecture sur ce scrutin elle dénonce
plusieurs vices de forme dans la
campagne de bernard de bas comparé à
présent un peu plus dans le sud du
département à rambouillet où on
attendait forcément de savoir si la
succession de gérard larcher se ferait
sans douleur l'actuel sénateur yvelinois
détenait depuis plus de 30 ans la ville
pour l'ump en annonçant qu'il ne
souhaitait pas se représenter il avait
placé ses espoirs marc robert l'un de
ses adjoints lors d'une précédente
mandature
à l'issue du second tour malgré la
présence de cinq listes ce dernier
l'emportent avec 46 6% des suffrages la
liste divers gauche qui totalise moins
de 20% alors qu'europe écologie les
verts plafonne à 11%
à noter que la liste du candidat
frontiste fait moins bien qu'au premier
tour et perd 150 voix réactions depuis
rambouillet hier soir avec michael et me
d'euros et patrick jacques de dixmude
cinq listes au second tour permettait à
beaucoup de robots huit ans de pouvoir
s'exprimer c'est bien ainsi d'ailleurs
je trouvais que quelque part les
rapprochements qui n'ont pas pu se faire
au premier tour c'était aussi bien que
cela aujourd'hui les résultats se sont
prononcés pour chacune de leurs
convictions
aujourd'hui elles sont elles sont elles
sont là donc les rambolitains me suivait
et souhaite que je sois leur mère jeu
comme je dis hein je serai le maire de
tous les rambolitains bien évidemment
c'est aussi vous l'avez compris ce soir
j'imagine un moment d'émotion parce que
je je je vais prendre la succession d'un
personnage gérard larcher qui me laisse
une ville solide une ville de qualité
avec une qualité de vie une identité et
que le challenge pour moi avec mes
colistiers bien c'est de poursuivre ce
chemin mais j'ai un bel exemple derrière
moi
la garde des valeurs
autre annonce de social ou la chirac
semblent eux mais je suis certain que ce
soit le maire de tous on pouvait pas
renversé la vapeur avec le premier tour
est la différence avec ma grand mère
était elle c'était impossible donc en
tenant compte de cela on s'en tire
plutôt bien puisqu'on reste le premier
groupe d'opposition qu'on a trois élus
au conseil municipal
les autres groupes d'opposition auront
deux et qu'on obtient deux élus au
conseil de la communauté de communes les
autres groupes d'opposition en auront un
donc on pourra toujours parler haut et
fort et veiller au grain pendant le
mandat qui vient comme on l'a fait dans
le dernier mandat
l'ump qui progresse fortement au niveau
national et qui progresse également
fortement dans les yvelines mainmise de
l'ump dans le département c'est l'un des
enseignements en local de ce scrutin le
réveil a été difficile pour la gauche ce
matin dans le département une vague
bleue sans précédent dans les yvelines
déjà largement ancrée à droite le
département est quasiment sous le
contrôle de l'ump de son allié lui delhi
sous l'impulsion national de nombreux
bastions socialistes dans les yvelines
tombe à l'issue de ces municipales de
maurepas à bois d'arcy en passant par
conflans sainte honorine où le président
de région jean paul huchon a été
notamment maire je veux dire que les
élections qui allaient des pommes mais
qu on progresse et j'ajoute aussi que
dans les villes il y à un label de
qualité des questions des droits des
bastions communistes aussi pasta droite
dont enchère mais la victoire la plus
emblématique pour l'ump reste celle de
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
en plus cette skis qui le vraiment le
système de développement un des gros
seins des gros bastions de développent
pour développer l'économie
et emploi qui est quand même la première
attente des français on est très content
bien sûr de gier est de pouvoir
reprendre en main la responsabilité des
élus sera de continuer cette réussite
quelles que soient les élus quels que
soient les élus quelle que soit la
direction notre responsabilité devant
devant les habitants de leur entreprise
devant nous nos enfants c'est de
continuer cette réussite et vous pouvez
compter sur moi pour passer la main dans
cette position là parce que l'oeuvre qui
a été accompli pour moi si le plus
important c'est qu'elle continue la
gauche ne détient plus qu'une poignée de
communes dans les yvelines dont quatre
qui composent l'agglomération de saint
quentin très satisfaite de voir que dans
un contexte national que nous vivons
pour le parti socialiste ce contexte des
fêtes
on a réussi sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin a conservé des villes à gauche
et avec des scores qui sont quand même
assez assez beau largement majoritaires
aux élections ces dernières années le ps
pourrait connaître une série de défaites
le 25 mai ce seront les élections
européennes
en septembre les sénatoriales et l'année
prochaine en 2015 les régionales et face
à cette progression de la droite le pcf
évoque je cite l'urgence absolue de
changer de politique à commencer par le
pacte d'irresponsabilité dictée par le
medef et la commission européenne pcf et
front de gauche qui appelle maintenant
que je cite toujours ce communiqué de
presse à une riposte à la droite pour un
changement de cap à gauche les deux
formations donne rendez vous à ses
sympathisants le 12 avril dans la rue
pour une manifestation
les discours de satisfaction en revanche
au front national les listes du
rassemblement bleu marine réalisent
l'objectif fixé par la direction
départementale d'installer et des
conseillers municipaux à plaisir
montigny le bretonneux versailles
également elancourt
elle met aussi à rambouillet où se
présentait le responsable départemental
de la formation que l'on entendra dans
un instant et puis à mantes-la-ville le
front national s'impose cyril note
enseignants de 32 ans arrache la commune
au ps avec 32 26% des voix un score qui
s'explique en partie par la division 4
listes se présentait sur le second tour
mantes-la-ville est la seule ville d'île
de france détenu maintenant par le front
national
on va de très bons scores
on récolte de 40 sièges de conseiller
municipal et 11 sièges des conseillers
communautaires et surtout essayer d
ankara face à la mairie de mantes la
ville qui était donc conclu par thiéry
notre et dois vous dire que monsieur
jean marie le pen et partez vite
particulièrement content que son
candidat ait pu donc et de triste
mémoire pour le front national marine le
pen l'a téléphone ces 400 par nos
conseillers municipaux donc s'effectuer
mêlant bon si on s'y attendait pas c'est
très au delà
cetrel au delà de deux étaient attendus
voilà ce qu'il faut donc retenir de ce
scrutin des municipales dans le
département des yvelines lac tueur
viendra demain à 18h sûreté défile
toujours en direct l'invité de cette
édition ce sera là grégory gare et stylé
nouveau maire de maurepas qui arrache
donc au maire divers gauche georges
mougeot la commune pour l'ump non sans
surprise votre soirée sur tv fils c'est
notamment avec anthony rech pour le 7-8
sports au programme
handball basket également avec les
présidents départementaux de ces deux
formations à demain bonne soirée